bonjour tout le monde
donc vous avez sans doute remarqué que
plusieurs personnes dans la salle ont
actuellement une chemise comme ça sur
leur siège
je vais demander aux personnes qui
possèdent cette chemise là de se lever
et aux autres personnes de rester assis
c'est bon tout le monde est debout
ok je veux pour vous regarder les uns
les autres et que vous réfléchissiez aux
différents rôles que vous incarnez dans
vos vies vous êtes des pères des mères
des frères des soeurs des conjoints des
enfants des amis ou même des collègues
de travail et les personnes actuellement
deux bouts représente le 20 pour cent de
la population canadienne qui sera
atteint d'un trouble de santé mentale au
cours de sa vie c'est une personne sur
cinq est à toutes ces personnes là que
génomique va directement touchées par la
maladie mentale
tout comme l'entourage de ces personnes
là mais il peut s'agir de nos mains et
considérant que nous avons tous une
santé mentale et que nous devons tous en
prendre soin ils disent que je m'apprête
à vous dire concerne cinq personnes sur
cinq
vous pouvez vous rasseoir
je suis né en 1992 à montréal de parents
d'origine haïtienne j'ai aujourd'hui 22
ans j'ai plusieurs choses dans la vie
des choses qui me passionnent quiberon
de redit qu'ils font sentir vivante
cependant la vie n'a pas toujours été
ainsi pour moi il ya cinq ans presque
jour pour jour
j'ai moi aussi reçu un diagnostic de
maladie mentale
j'avais 17 ans quand thomas tennistique
est un trouble bipolaire quelques jours
me séparer de mon 18e anniversaire une
entrée qui fut brutal dans l'âge adulte
dans mon corps l'hérédité et les
expériences de vie difficiles explique
le déclenchement de la maladie
j'ai vécu de l'intimidation en milieu
scolaire diverses problématiques
familiales qui ont mené à la séparation
des parents
j'ai vécu une peine d'amour que les
effets dévastateurs sur moi j'ai
souffert au point d'en avoir mal
physiquement dans la douleur
psychologique était forte et si simple
cette maladie m'a volé l'innocence et la
naïveté qui caractérise les jeunes de
mon âge j'ai rapidement compris que
personne ne me s'ouvrait si je ne savais
pas moi mais vous savez j'ai souffert
énormément même avis a pris une autre
direction
j'ai 22 ans et je suis aujourd'hui
rétablie
en tant qu un terme aux normes sociales
j'entends souvent les gens autour de moi
dire que le rétablissement santé mentale
n'est pas possible pour tous je crois
profondément le contraire quand on
surmonte une épreuve comme celle ci on
développe une force une résilience
insoupçonnées cependant plusieurs
éléments sont nécessaires pour reprendre
le pouvoir sur son existence et les
éléments que je m'apprête à vous
présenter sont solidement documenté
appuyée par la recherche et les études
qui ont été menées sur cette notion de
rétablissement santé mentale mais tout
d'abord il faut s'entend sur une chose
qu'est ce que le rétablissement et
qu'est ce qu'il n'est pas
les personnes vivant avec un trouble de
santé mentale peuvent se rétablir avec
ou sans l'aide du système de la santé
mentale les personnes en rétablissement
ont été réellement malade
c'est un processus qui est non linéaire
qui comporte des périodes d'avancé de
recul et même de stagnation le
rétablissement est possible même si une
personne continuait à voir des symptômes
de son trouble psychique
le processus de rétablissement est de la
diminution et à la durée des symptômes
personne ne peut se prononcer sur les
chances qualications de se rétablir et
la présence de réseau social fort qui
croient que la personne peut s'en sortir
est cruciale dans ce processus
au cours de mon adolescence j'ai eu la
chance de faire la rencontre
d'enseignants et d'adultes significatifs
qui accordait de la valeur à mes propos
et à la personne que j'étais
contrairement à la plupart de mes
camarades de classe ils m'ont assuré que
j'aurai ma revanche contre tous ceux qui
ont aussi de me mettre à terre il voyait
un potentiel en moi il me le répétait
souvent les gens n'étaient dixie québec
en font également partie
c'est grâce à toutes ces personnes là
que j'ai pu retrouver l'espoir d'une vie
meilleure
sans leur présence et leur soutien je
doute fortement que je sois ici parmi
vous aujourd'hui se rétablit et ce n'est
pas un événement si un processus qui
prend du temps pour ma part j'ai eu le
sentiment d'être morte vivant pendant
plusieurs années en raison de la maladie
mais également raison de toutes les
épreuves que je vivais à différents
niveaux
le rétablissement ne signifie pas la
guérison je ne guérirai jamais de mon
trouble bipolaire
cependant j'ai appris à me connaître à
connaître comment les symptômes se
manifestent chez moi et à mener une vie
épanouissante
malgré ceci les usages en rétablissement
ne sont pas des cas isolés des tas et
des tas d'exemples de personnes rita
abbey existe autour de moi je pense
totalement mon ami luc vigneault à pair
aidant fort comme une amie de la santé
mentale au québec est ici aujourd'hui
on peut donc dire que le rétablissement
est un processus de reprise de contrôle
sur sa vie et de la direction que l'on
veut lui donner et ce au delà du design
psychiatriques et des pertes y étant
habituellement à ceux ci j'ai mentionné
que la plupart des personnes vivant avec
un trouble de santé mentale se
rétablisse elle se rétablissent en
raison de dix composantes que voici la
première étant l'autodétermination la
capacité à déterminer son propre chemin
le projet de l'établissement peut être
menée par la personne qui est
directement concernée par celui ci dans
mon coeur la pierre angulaire de mort
établissement a été mon choix
d'étudiants l'intervention sociale une
approche individualisée et centrée sur
la personne
il ya différents parcours quand on parle
de santé mentale différents chemins
quand on parle de rétablissement je ne
représente pas à moi seul
tous les parcours qu'ils se donnent un
accès correct toutes les expériences se
valent le pouvoir d'agir ou les mains en
mains si la capacité à se joindre
à d'autres personnes ayant un vécu
similaires afin d'être plus fort je
pense notamment au porte-voix du
rétablissement
une association mené par et pour des
personnes ayant vécu un trouble de santé
mentale
la seule du genre au québec une vision
holistique et globale leur établissement
doit embrasser tous les aspects de la
vie d'une personne et de sa communauté
bon ça veut dire les familles les amis
les intervenants le système de la santé
des services sociaux mais également
l'emploi l'éducation le logement la
créativité même la spiritualité le
caractère non linéaire et j'insiste sur
ce point ce n'est pas un processus
étape par étape 6 1 3 6 6 avec une
croissance continue mais avec des
périodes de reculer devant chute par
maman mais la capacité de m'apprendre de
ces périodes l'option qui peuvent être
plus creuses je suis toujours en proie
de l'anxiété par maman cependant j'ai
développé des outils quand on a composé
avec celle ci un cheminement axée sur
les forces pour se rétablir
il faut partir des talents de la
résilience et de la valeur inhérente de
chaque individu
il faut faire sortir les personnes des
rôles stéréotypés et leur permet de
créer des nouveaux rôles l'entr'aide
entre les pères c'est le soutien mutuel
entre les personnes qui sont rétablis
envers celles qui se battent toujours
pour se rétablir le respect il faut
accepter et apprécier le vécu des
personnes vivant avec un trouble de
santé mentale
il faut protéger leurs droits mais il
est également éliminé la stigmatisation
et la discrimination à leur égard
notamment au milieu de travail
la responsabilisation les personnes
vivant avec un trouble de santé mentale
ne sont pas responsables de leur maladie
mais elles sont responsables de leur
rétablissement à tous les jours je pose
l'action compterait pour éviter la
rechute est qu'on ne pas aggraver
tuation je me mets tiens continuellement
dehors de ma zone de confort en prenons
des risques et des initiatives pour
avoir une estime personnelle qui est
beaucoup plus solide
je communique les changements que je
marchais mois aux professionnels qui
suivent et je suis leur recommandation
jamais loin des relations qui ne cause
du stress et je m'en bat i dont sont
beaucoup plus nourrissante pour moi et
finalement l'espoir l'espoir d'un
élément qui est cruciale dans ce
processus
il peut être alimenté par la personne
elle même mais également par son
entourage
la famille les amis les intervenants a
cédé rend donc selon dr digue est une
psychologue aux états unis qui a
beaucoup étudié cette question là il ya
trois grandes forces au processus de
rétablissement
la première une grande souffrance
psychologique
la deuxième la transformation de son
être et la troisième la re découverte de
soi
j'ai souffert mais si je suis aussi
heureux aujourd'hui c'est précisément
parce que j'ai connu la noirceur et dans
mon corps et dans le cas de plusieurs
personnes rétabli et pour reprendre une
expression que j'aime beaucoup mais qui
n'est pas de moi la maladie mentale a
été un cadeau
marc abadie de la vie un cadeau partie
sera permis de redéfinir mes priorités
est de redéfinir la direction que je
voulais donner un mon existence
tout ceci est bien beau direz vous mais
à plusieurs obstacles au rétablissement
la climatisation en est un majeur
une tournée de consultation a été menée
en 2010 jusqu'en 2012 auprès de plus de
250 personnes vivant avec un trouble
psychique la lutte l'association a été
ciblé comme la deuxième priorité pour
ces personnes de plus beaucoup
d'individus vous diront que vivre avec
la stigmatisation est beaucoup plus
lourd que vivent les cas maladie
elle-même 57% de 567 6 kg à son départ
le michigan s'est caché sous sa élit ont
illuminé qui se soignerait
dans le secret plutôt que de voir un
diagnostic psychiatrique apparaissent à
leur dossier médical
la situation est aussi le plus grand
obstacle à l'intégration sociale des
personnes atteintes
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé pour contrer la stigmatisation et
ainsi favoriser l'établissement
il ya plusieurs options qui fonctionne
bien l'une d'entre elles est la
combinaison de l'éducation et de la mise
en avant des modèles positifs de
rétablissement de plus le fait
d'embaucher dans le système de la santé
mentale des personnes ayant vécu de
santé mentale et qui sont rétablis
fonctionne beaucoup mieux que les
coûteuses campagnes de sensibilisation
et c'est ce que je tente de faire
aujourd'hui en partageant mon histoire
je veux être le changement que je veux
voir dans le monde et mon histoire se
termine bien aujourd'hui j'ai vingt deux
ans si intervenante sociale
j'ai un dec en les tabassant délinquance
au code du collège ahuntsic
je suis actuellement le travail social
de l'acheter mais gai
j'ai eu la chance de terminer les médias
plusieurs reprises pour parler de
problématiques sociales j'ai gagné
plusieurs baux des cieux pour mon
engagement social et musulmans
académique
j'ai repris le dessus sur la maladie les
personnes vivant avec un trouble de
santé mentale sont des héros qui
combattent dans l'ombre
j'ai décidé que je voulais plus être
l'héroïne se cachent quand l'accord et
pour reprendre les propos d'une
chanteuse québécois fait jamais
nommément dion de marry me beaucoup de
gens vivent leur vie en ayant peur de
viser les étoiles
j'ai décidé que je voulais pas vivre à
marie ainsi en conclusion je vous
souhaite une pionnière sur la question
du rétablissement au québec
le rétablissement d'un processus unique
débutant la la personne décide de ne
plus donner le pouvoir à la maladie de
contrôler toute seule je me suis re
découvertes mes capacités et mes rêves
je me suis donné de nouvelles
possibilités avec ou sans la présence de
symptômes de limites
aujourd'hui par la maladie mentale si
l'espoir d'une vie meilleure